GREG CASTLE: Hi, I'm Greg.
I'm the Anthos GKE security
tech lead at Google.
SAMRAT RAY: Hi, I'm Samrat Ray.
I'm the Anthos security product
management lead at Google.
GREG CASTLE: So today we're
talking about Anthos security.
We wanted to start
with the takeaways
that we're going to get
from this presentation.
First up is we want you
to be able to understand
how Anthos improves security
across a hybrid production
environment.
Next is there's a lot
of products and features
in this presentation--
there's about 30 of them.
So we want to make
sure that we're
being really obvious and
deliberate about where
each feature is available and
which environment on which
platform it's available.
Really, the high-level thing
we want to leave you with here
is a four-step
high-level workflow
to configure Anthos
security across
multiple different platforms.
Just a quick note on names--
we've shortened some of the
names in this presentation
just to make things
a bit easier to say
and to fit them on diagrams,
so using GKE for Anthos
on Google cloud.
This presentation is called
"Modernize Your Security
Posture."
So what's being modernized?
And what industry
trends are driving that?
We think these three
things are happening.
First is there's not just
one production security
infrastructure to
harden anymore.
There's multiple-- on-prem
and there's multiple clouds.
Second-- Kubernetes
and containers
have really changed a lot
of our security assumptions
about production infrastructure.
So previously we might
have had an application
running on a virtual machine
with always the same IP,
whereas in Kubernetes
and containers,
we have applications
being dynamically scaled,
scheduled across different
virtual machines,
and with dynamically
allocated IPs.
And that's quite a difference
in security properties.
We also have these big monoliths
that have been broken down
into microservices.
And all of those
microservices now
need authentication
and authorization
to be able to talk
to each other.
And that needs to happen
inside the perimeter.
So this is where Anthos really
starts to come in and help.
If we look at this hybrid
infrastructure where we have
clusters running on Google
Cloud, other clouds,
and on-prem, the four points at
the top are really where Anthos
is helping you--
at the infrastructure level,
at a separate policy layer,
with services and
application security,
and with monitoring
and detection.
And so we took those
four kind of concepts
and we turned them
into these four steps
that you can use to
harden applications
and get secure deployments
across a hybrid infrastructure.
So the first step we're going
to talk through is hardening--
how do you do
patching, compliance,
hardening configuration.
Next, guardrails-- how do you
segment, isolate, and apply
that policy across
lots of clusters?
Securing workloads-- how do
you only run what you trust
and have really
fine-grained authorization?
And monitoring detection--
once you've done all of that,
how do you find
misconfigurations and detect
attackers doing bad
things to clusters?
We want to be able to do
these four things across all
of your different environments.
So let's start with
hardening the infrastructure.
And the spoiler
for this section is
we've basically done
most of this for you,
but we're going to talk through
a whole lot of work that's
happening behind the
scenes so that you
know that it's happening.
So starting with security
patching and hardening,
if we look at a big stack
of technology for Kubernetes
clusters, everything from
the hardware right up
to application
containers, each one
of these layers at
some point probably
needs security patching, and
it definitely needs hardening.
So when we're running on our
own infrastructure with GKE,
we've basically taking the
responsibility for most
of that technology stack.
For our Anthos that isn't
GKE, so on-prem and AWS,
we're selling a little
further up because we're
running on that infrastructure
that the customers provided,
so the VMs running on-prem
or the virtual machines
running in AWS or other clouds.
So it's more of a
responsibility sandwich,
we like to call this one.
But we're still doing a lot
of work in the middle there.
So where we do control
that infrastructure on GKE,
we can deliver some pretty cool
advanced security functionality
that's on by default or is
exposed with really simplified
configuration.
So some of the things we're
doing, moving from the bottom
up in this diagram, the
first thing we'll talk about
is Shielded VMs and nodes.
So these features give
us verifiable integrity
from our Titan
hardware security chip
and the integrity of
the underlying firmware
and up through the kernel.
And then we have
the virtual TPM that
gives us a secure
bootstrap and a way
to join the node to
the cluster securely.
Customer managed encryption
keys for disk encryption.
So every VM is
encrypted automatically
by default in Google
Cloud with a key that is
managed by Google internally.
If you want to re-encryt that
VM again, re-encrypt the disk
again, you can do that using
managed encryption keys
that you store in Cloud KMS.
And a similar feature
for Kubernetes secrets.
You can encrypt Kubernetes
secrets using a Cloud
KMS managed key as well.
The control plane and the node--
the cluster infrastructure
itself--
automatically upgrades
itself by default on GKE.
So if you create a cluster
and just leave it there
and do nothing to it, it'll
just keep upgrading itself
and keep itself in a good,
security configuration.
We also offer some control
over how those upgrades happen.
We have different
release channels--
rapid, regular, and
stable-- that you
can choose to
really sort of dial
up or down how quickly
those updates are
happening on your clusters.
There's also additional features
like maintenance windows
and exclusions.
So let's talk a little
bit about compliance
starting with the
Kubernetes CIS benchmark.
So the Center for
Internet Security
has created a
Kubernetes benchmark
that tells you how to run
Kubernetes in a hardened
configuration.
There's really a lot of
settings in this benchmark.
And we've done the hard work
to configure all those settings
in the best possible
way, and we've
published our full results
for GKE and for on-prem.
We've also developed a
GKE-specific CIS benchmark
that basically just
takes our hardening guide
and gives you that
in a checklist form.
The infrastructure
itself, we've had
a bunch of compliance
coverage there,
so various standards
listed here.
This is for GKE.
We're also working on compliance
coverage for infrastructure
in the other hybrid environments
that we're offering.
And we expect to make some
more announcements there soon.
That's the infrastructure layer.
The next layer up when you want
to build an application that
is itself compliant, we're then
providing some solution guides
such as for PCI for
GKE that basically
help you write that
PCI application on top
of GKE infrastructure.
And we're also working
on additional guides
for additional platforms
and standards here too.
So summing up this
section, Anthos really
does most of the
work for you here
across all of the platforms.
If you follow our guidelines
for multitenancy on GKE,
there's a bit of extra
information in there
about how to structure projects,
how to put them in folders,
and how to create DPCs.
For on-prem and
GKE, you can then
follow the hardening guides to
create the clusters themselves.
And on top of that,
follow the solution guides
to make the applications
that run in clusters.
All the links are provided here.
So once you've
made some clusters
and have some
infrastructure to use,
you really want to
establish some guardrails
around that infrastructure
and make sure it's
being used appropriately.
The really key feature here
is Anthos Config Management.
And this gives us
the ability to manage
cross-cluster and cross-cloud
a lot of different policies.
And the idea here is
to use a GitOps model
where our infrastructure
as code is really checked
into our source control.
So the idea there
is that when we're
using source control to
manage infrastructure,
we have automatic review.
We have a history.
We have a way to
templatize and create
new pieces of
infrastructure easily.
So looking at how
this works for Anthos,
we used Terraform
to make the kind
of base layer of infrastructure,
things like projects
and VPCs and clusters.
And then the next layer
is where ACM comes in.
So ACM Config Sync is generally
available across all three
Anthos platforms here.
And that gives you the ability
to create namespaces, configure
RBAC, security
controls, and also
create identities
through service accounts,
and really actually manage
any Kubernetes object at scale
across many clusters across all
the hybrid environments here.
You can also go even further.
And if you like the declarative
kind of [? configures ?]
code approach, you can use it to
also create your GCP resources
using GCP config connector.
And the idea here
is that if you want
to-- if your application
needs a Pub/Sub instance,
you could write a
piece of YAML that
goes along with all of your
other YAMLs for Kubernetes.
And you can try a Kube control
apply, all of those at once
and have both the pod started
as well as the GCP resources
that those applications need.
That's also GA across
GKE and on-prem.
So ACM config sync
kind of sets us up
in this base infrastructure
security configuration.
Policy controller
is a feature that
also works across all
three environments here,
and it allows us
to really control
what the pods are doing
inside that cluster.
So the idea here is
you want to make sure
that containers aren't doing
things like running as root,
unaccessing the host network,
unaccessing the host powers,
and doing other
dangerous things.
So we give you a really
comprehensive policy library
that you can apply
to your clusters.
And that policy
library as an example
here of not running as root--
that policy library
is written using
open policy agent's gatekeeper,
so a open source policy
language.
So both of those features
are available across all
the environments to use today.
They're all GA.
There's a couple of extra things
we can talk about on GKE when
you're running on GKE itself.
The first is org policies.
So org policies sit above
all of your clusters,
above all your projects.
And they allow you to
have like a macro policy
control across many objects.
So one thing you can do is
restrict regions for resources.
So if you just want
to run in the US,
you can make an org policy that
says that for Google Cloud.
Another thing you can do
for your Kubernetes clusters
is to restrict how services
are exposed to the internet.
Most organizations want to
avoid someone accidentally
putting a untested or a kind of
poorly configured application
accidentally on the internet.
And this is a way to
make sure that doesn't
happen with your GKE clusters.
Another guardrail of
technology on GKE cloud
is VPC service controls.
This technology allows us to
have some confidence that when
we've put some
information in cloud
storage or other
similar cloud resources
on GCP that it's
not going to easily
be exfiltrated by a bad guy.
So there's a few scenarios
that it protects against.
Imagine someone accidentally
messing up a access control
rule on a cloud storage
bucket and making
it public for everyone to read.
The VPC would still
protect that scenario,
because there's a
perimeter around there that
says those cloud storage
buckets should only be accessed
from authorized VPCs.
In a similar fashion, if one
of your computer resources
happen to get
compromised, it would also
make it more difficult to
exfiltrate that data out
from the cloud by establishing
the same perimeter
and only allowing the
traffic to flow out
on the authorized VPCs.
So private GKE clusters
can be established
inside the perimeter.
So they're not on the internet.
You can also do the same
with Container Registry
with your container images.
And VPC service
controls supports
hybrid in that you can connect
your hybrid on-prem networks
by using Cloud
Interconnect or cloud VPN.
So just summing up
this section, we
want to use ACM to do the
vast majority of our policy
configuration enforcement across
our hybrid infrastructure.
Then on GKE cloud, we
have some extra controls
that we can use to establish
some extra guardrails.
So that's the end of
the guardrails section.
I'm now going to hand
it over to Samrat
to talk about how to
secure our workloads.
SAMRAT RAY: Thanks, Greg.
We have now covered
how to configure
a secure infrastructure
and set up guardrails.
You are now ready
to deploy workloads
to this secure landing zone.
Let us look at how you can
secure workloads with Anthos.
Anthos provides tools
to implement a defense
in depth architecture, or
a zero trust architecture,
if you like.
We have provided here
four steps that you
can use to secure
workloads on Anthos,
the first being
securing your build
and deployment
pipelines, ensuring
that your entire supply chain
for your code from source
to your production is secure.
The second is to ensure
that all workloads deployed
to production are appropriately
isolated from the internet
and from each other within
your production [INAUDIBLE]..
You should also isolate
your pods on the node
if multiple applications are
deployed on a single cluster.
Lastly, you want to
ensure that services
that are exposed
to the internet are
done so with appropriate
protection against internet
facing attacks.
So let's go through
the first step, which
is to secure workloads.
The objective of
securing workloads
is to ensure that
only trusted code can
be deployed to production.
To ensure that, we recommend you
lock down your CICD pipelines,
ensure that you use
a secure base image,
scan that base build
image for vulnerabilities.
Google Cloud's
Container Registry
provides incremental and
continuous monitoring
against a known
vulnerability database.
The output of the scans
are available as metadata
with your pod.
The fact that you have gone
through all the above steps
can be asserted using
binary authorization.
Binary authorization allows
you to define a policy
that checks for attestation
from each step of your
build pipeline.
You can leverage
the tools provided
by GCP for building and
deploying your containers.
Or you can bring your own
build and deployment tools
as long as they have
testers that are trusted
by binary authorization.
Only workloads that have
the right attestations
can be deployed to production.
All deployment and
denials are audited
by binary authorization.
You can now trust the
code running in production
with a privileged identity.
The next step is to
isolate the deployed code
from the internet.
This can be achieved by ensuring
that all clusters are private
and any service that is
exposed to the internet
is done so using an internet
facing load balancer.
Google Cloud's load balancer
provides industry-leading DDoS
protection.
Further, you can configure web
application firewall policies
via Cloud Armor.
You can also configure
zero trust access
by your employees using
identity via proxy.
In addition to isolating the
applications from the internet,
it is also necessary to isolate
workloads from each other
to prevent the lateral
movement of [INAUDIBLE]..
We'd need to prevent lateral
movements over the network,
but also between pods
on the same node.
Anthos provides
two technologies--
Anthos service mesh and
Kubernetes network policy
to isolate workloads
on the network.
Anthos also provides
two technologies--
GKE Sandbox and AppArmor--
to isolate applications
on the [INAUDIBLE]..
Let's learn more about
these technologies.
A common approach with
Anthos is to create
clusters that are shared
across multiple teams.
Each team gets one
or more name spaces
into which to deploy their
application workloads.
Thus, namespaces form a
natural boundary for isolation.
Kubernetes network policy allows
you to isolate applications
on a single cluster
based on namespaces.
You can then define
ingress and egress rules
based on IP CIDRs or Kubernetes
objects such as namespaces
and labels.
This approach can be called
as micro-segmentation.
It's a good approach if you
don't have too many exceptions
to manage.
However, in many cases, we
have seen through experience
that there are a lot of
east-west communications
between applications.
And we implement shared
services which break isolation.
Thus, we recommend using
coarse-grained segments
for mandatory controls and
defining fine-grained policies
at the application level.
So you can define
application-level policies
and an end-to-end zero
trust access solution
using Anthos service mesh
and identity via proxy.
With Anthos service
mesh, all communications
are encrypted in transit.
Further, all
workload-to-workload
communications can be
strongly authenticated,
authorized, and logged.
Workloads are authenticated
using certificates
instead of bare tokens.
Using mutual TLS for
authentication helps mitigate
the risk of impersonation and
privilege escalation through
replay or
man-in-the-middle attacks.
ASM also provides you with
context of our policies
that allows you to define access
controls based on peer request
and application contexts.
For example, you can state that
only credit card front end can
access credit card back end.
You do this in
terms of identities.
Thus, credit card front end
can be deployed anywhere,
and access policy remains
the same irrespective
of the network context
of credit card front end.
You can also state that
credit card front end
can only access PII
when it presents
an end user credential, i.e.
a valid JWT token that
has the right claims.
Thus, with Anthos
service mesh, you
can reduce the privilege of
the credit card front end
with respect to
PII, but also ensure
that all access to
your credit card data
happens only through the
credit card front end.
On GCP, we provide
identity via proxy
for authenticating
and authorizing
user access based on
BeyondCorp principles.
You can also use your own
user authentication solution
with Anthos service mesh.
And you can do all of
this without changing
your application code.
Depending on your
security profile
and what your
application is, you
might want a second
layer of isolation
between your container
workloads on a shared host.
Anthos provides two
solutions for isolating
pods on a shared node.
The first one is GKE Sandbox,
which is available on GCP.
And the second is AppArmor,
which is now in beta,
but is available on
all environments.
GKE Sandbox is based upon
an open source project
gVisor that uses a user space
kernel to intercept and handle
[? cis ?] calls.
Thus, you're reducing the
interaction with the host
and reducing the attack surface.
We have now made this
available to you in Anthos
as the GKE Sandbox, which can be
enabled with a one-line change.
With AppArmor, on
the other hand,
you can define and
reduce the privileges
accessible by an application.
You need to define
application-specific profiles
with AppArmor.
So let us now look at a
summary of this section.
So we provide a defense
in depth approach
to secure your
workloads from securing
your build and
deployment pipelines
to isolating your
applications on the network.
And we can do that with
a different in depth
approach using
segmentation and zero trust
approach with
Anthos service mesh
and isolating your
pods on a shared node.
And finally, we
provide you the ability
to protect your internet exposed
services using Google Cloud
load balancer and CloudArmor.
Now let us look
at the fourth step
to secure your
applications with Anthos.
The fourth step is to enable
monitoring and detection
for any incidents.
Now, you have done your best to
configure everything securely,
but how do you know
you did it right?
In order to know
that, we provide you
with the three-layered stack.
Going from the
bottom, we provide you
with Security Health Analytics
and the Security Scanner that
analyzes your configuration
to prevent threats
because of a misconfiguration.
The layer above that is a set of
threat detection capabilities,
which is the container threat
detection, event threat
detection, and
Access Transparency.
Access Transparency
enables you to understand
how a Google administrator may
have access to your resources.
And all of this information is
available through a single pane
of glass via the Cloud
Security Command Center.
If you want to bring your
own visibility tools,
we allow you to do that.
And you can integrate
those tools at two levels.
You can export all
your allowed events
and logs that you need via
Pub/Sub for easy integration,
and use your own security
visibility and analysis tools
with Anthos.
So let's understand a bit
more about Security Health
Analytics.
Security Health Analytics
helps prevent threats
by telling you about
problems before they
get exploited by an attacker.
SHA alerts you to
misconfiguration errors.
In the context of
GKE, an example
is an old cluster running
an insecure authentication
mechanism.
We also provide Web
Security Scanner,
which identifies issues
with web applications.
The results of the analysis
are displayed in Cloud Security
Command Center.
Another tool to understand is
the Container Threat Detection.
Container Threat Detection helps
you detect potential attacks
in real time by monitoring
for suspicious behavior
inside containers
that will indicate
that they are compromised.
These include things like
downloading and running
new binaries.
In addition to container
threat detection,
we also provide event threat
detection for suspicious events
and logs, such as traffic
to known bad domains and IPs
and crypto-mining.
Again, you can see the findings
in Cloud Security Command
Center.
To summarize this
section on GCP,
we provide a number of tools to
help you analyze your posture
and detect incidents.
This information is available
in Cloud Security Command Center
or a tool of your choice.
You can view all your alerts
in the Cloud Security Command
Center.
And to recap what we
have just covered,
there are four steps to securing
your modern applications
using Anthos.
You harden your infrastructure.
You then establish guardrails.
Once you have a
secured landing zone,
you can now secure
your workloads
by securing your
deployment pipelines
and isolating your workloads
in your production environment.
And finally, you enable
monitoring and detection
to ensure that you
have the right posture
and that you are
alerted on incidents.
And you can enable
this four-step workflow
across all your
environments, whether it's
GCP or on-premise on AWS
and others in the future.
Thank you.